veamos si podemos calcular 2.91 por 3.2
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de hacer esta operación por su
cuenta la forma en que yo voy a pensar
en ello es que esté 2.91 es igual a
tener 200 91 entre 100 sabemos que si
dividimos algo entre 100 vamos a
desplazar el punto decimal dos lugares
hacia la izquierda de manera que nos
quedaría el punto acá 2.91 igual que
aquí de manera similar s 3.2 es lo mismo
que tener 32 entre 10 porque hacemos
esto porque puedo reescribir 2.91 por
3.2 como 2.91 por
3.2 esto es igual a
291 entre 100
x
entre 10
esto es igual a tener 291 por 32
entre 100
entre 10 escribimos bien este 2 y esto a
su vez es igual a tener 291 por 32 y
esto de aquí entre 100 y entre 10 es lo
mismo que tener entre 1000
bueno yo ya sé cómo multiplicar 291 por
32 y también sé cómo dividir entre 1000
calculemos 291 por 32 que es lo mismo
que daba original pero sin tomar en
cuenta los decimales aunque obviamente
son cantidades diferentes por eso al
final dividiré el resultado entre mil
291 por 32 nos da tomamos este 2 en las
unidades 2 por 12 2 por 9 18 llevamos 12
por 24 más una que llevamos 5
tomemos este 3 que por la posición es no
lo está es un 30 está de las decenas así
que es 30 por 1 es 30 aquí ponemos el 0
3 por 9 27 y llevó 2 esté lleno le hago
caso 3 por 2 6 + 2 que llevo son 8 y
ahora hago la suma 20 283 11 diego 157
son 12 113 aquí llevo 18 más 199 mil 312
así que esto es igual a esto de aquí
es igual a nueve mil 312 y ahora lo
único que nos falta es hacer la división
dividir esto entre 1000 que es lo mismo
que desplazar el punto decimal tres
lugares hacia la izquierda
si tenemos aquí el punto bueno ahorita
no lo pongo acá si yo tengo aquí 9.312
tengo aquí mi punto decimal lo voy a
desplazar 1 2 3 lugares ahora va a ir
aquí por lo que este resultado va a ser
9.312 así que esto que tengo acá esto
que tengo acá es lo que voy a tener acá
pero lo voy a dividir entre 1000 entre
1000 y me va a quedar este 9.312 como
resultado aquí sucede algo interesante
si nos fijamos en la operación original
tenemos un número a la derecha del punto
decimal otro número aquí van 2 y aquí
tenemos otro número a la derecha del
punto decimal tenemos 1 2 3 y
curiosamente el resultado tiene 3
números a la derecha del punto decimal
tiene 123 porque es esto pensemos en
ello nosotros re expresamos 2.91 como
291 entre 100
aquí es 291
entre 100 y 3.2 como 32 entre 10 dividir
entre 100 y entre 10 cuenta por estos
tres números después del punto decimal
así que al hacer la operación no tomamos
en cuenta los decimales pero al final si
los usamos al inicio movimos el punto
decimal dos lugares a la derecha aquí
arriba como está aquí y un lugar a la
derecha aquí abajo y al final de la
operación desplazamos el punto tres
lugares hacia la izquierda en resumen
tenemos que este 2.91 lo multiplicamos
por 100 básicamente para tener 291 al 32
lo multiplicamos por 10 perdón al 3.2 lo
multiplicamos por 10 para tener un
entero no tener este número decimal para
tener un 32 al agregar esto lo
multiplicamos por 1000 y al final este
resultado lo dividimos y de hecho acabo
de notar que me equivoqué entre
aquí nos salió el tercer cero lo
dividimos entre 1000 el resultado por
eso se desplazó tres lugares hacia la
izquierda y con eso terminamos este
vídeo